alright let's talk about systemic racism
or at least the idea of systemic racism
so I think you've seen the video of me
about two or two and a half years ago
with Larry elder and I brought up
systemic racism larry elder proceeded to
commit a hate crime on me a white man he
beat me senseless with statistics yeah
and I came to a fight not ready to to
fight basically and that was definitely
one of my red pill moments so to speak I
was not prepared
I heard new information I did research
after that subsequently I've had many
people on this show and many
conversations that have led me to more
of Larry's original premise so I guess
first when you when you saw that moment
was that the first time you had ever
seen me do anything because that's a
little tell me and I'm like oh I don't
think it was the first time but I think
I mean I don't and envied anyone who is
debating Larry elder on anything
he's pretty devastating but I've been
kind of refreshing though when you saw
this moment where he laid it out yeah
you know there was no counter because
there is no counter right well yeah he
he what he did with you there is he he
went through each specific venue in
which supposedly there is this big
systemic racism problem where the system
is rigged in such a way that it doesn't
require any individual in the system to
be racist in order for the system to
spit out racist outcomes that's
essentially the idea of systemic racism
so he went he went with you through he
said just name name a place in society
where you think systemic racism exists
and he just did basically destroyed each
one with the specifics of of the case
and I'm not gonna do a better job than
he did there yeah he's capable of doing
but there there's a bigger picture way
to test the systemic racism hypothesis
which is to take to populations where
it's it's a very messy crude science
experiment but to take to populations
where you're holding systemic race
constant namely black Americans like
myself and black immigrants especially
black immigrants from the West Indies
and their children we're talking about
immigrants from Jamaica Barbados other
places in the West Indies and
specifically their children their
american-born children so these are
people you could not tell apart from
black like you couldn't tell if I didn't
tell you that I wasn't the child of a
Jamaican immigrant or something right
and you find that the thing about these
is that these two populations differ in
many ways some some some ways are very
hard to quantify but they differ
culturally they differ for all kinds of
reasons because partially because the
kind of immigrant who gets out of a
Jamaica differs systematically is going
to be disproportionately intelligent
disproportionately hard-working whatever
the traits are that get you from Jamaica
to New York say that's a cluster of
attributes that that makes that
population differ but there's there's
one thing that is not different which is
they are subjected to whatever level of
systemic racism exists so Thomas ol has
done good work on it back in the 70s he
showed that second-generation West in
the West Indians living in the same city
as black Americans were earning 58% more
right so they're they're both being
treated to whatever degree badly by
white people they're whatever this
whatever system you want to suppose is
holding black people back is equally
affecting both of them the Columbia
sociologist van tranh has a great essay
in which the this this difference is
brought out you find neighborhoods of of
black Americans right next to
neighborhoods of black West Indians in
New York they're equally segregated from
white people so it gets rid of you know
this the idea that being segregated by a
cell or living around people who only
look like you is inherently a
disadvantage it gets around the policing
issue because these populations are
being polluted the police can't tell the
difference between a second-generation
white
and a black person it gets around
whatever level of systemic racism is or
isn't in the pipeline with regard to
schools and you find wildly different
outcomes you find you know rate of high
school graduation much higher for black
West Indians a rate of enrollment in
college much higher i'm a rate of
professional occupations much higher
crime lower right so this suggests to me
that there are that the role of systemic
racism tool to whatever degree it exists
is is minimal at this point and the the
the there's a whole narrative built
around the idea that this is the primary
obstacle facing black people and it's
worth noting I don't I don't think most
black people actually believe this
because I mean they're they're various
polls to cite here but there's there's
one from Pew that that asked black
people without without college education
has has race has your race held you back
at all in life 60 percent said no it's a
recent Pew poll another Gallup poll
asked is bias the main issue facing you
in jobs and housing sixty percent again
said no the the Harvard sociologist
Ethan Fawcett polling of the black
community and found that disconnected
black youth which would be a black youth
without who aren't in schools and don't
have a jobs the people on the lowest
rung of society something something
around thirty percent of them think the
system is rigged and seventy percent
don't so what we're getting is we're
getting the voices of black people who
believe the systemic racism narrative
promoted to the to the most powerful
media positions in our country so we're
getting the impression right this is a
uniform view and it's not right so this
is sort of the Jesse Jackson South sharp
as they get moved up because they're
given sort of simple answers right so I
guess it harkens the question that I
could ask this either way what is it
that the West Indian
are doing right or what is it that the
other folks are doing wrong yeah yeah I
mean you can answer that in either
directions I'll show first well part of
it is just immigration selection factors
that I mentioned right so the the kind
of Jamaican or Barbadian who makes it
off the island to New York did likely to
be disproportionately hard-working disp
report will disproportionately x4
whatever X Factor is and so in that
sense the direct comparison can be
misleading but just analyzing why these
two populations differ you find West
Indian immigrants more likely to come
from a two-parent home you know more
likely to have had a more classically
socially conservative upbringing which
is you know you don't talk back to your
parents parents are rather strict there
are downsides of course to that style of
parenting but basically what I'm saying
is that there are cultural factors that
are important that differ between these
two groups right you find if they're
armed there are many I mean this is this
is where the conversation for many
people gets especially uncommon yeah
right it's the idea that every culture
every subculture is identical in the
behavioral patterns that are inculcated
and wherever there is some wherever
there is a disparity in some outcome
it's not possible that culture accounts
for some or most of that disparity which
i think is a very silly idea well
completely nonsensical jurors are
different different people and different
groups put different emphasis on certain
things so more on family simple more on
Education simple more on sports or
whatever the hell whatever the hell it
is so when you hear larry elder make the
argument you know something around until
1972 the black family had a higher rate
of staying in marriages and then he lays
out the reasons that he believes
policies of the democrats destroyed all
that that that obviously resonates with
you right because you're you're giving
me some piece of this both answers I
think resonated or went back to family
of marriage and some sort of
conservative ideals right well yeah I
mean that that's a very complex people
hate when you talk when everyone talks
about
yes about family people just absolutely
hate it it is a fact that black that the
rate of two-parent homes and marriages
was pretty similar to the white rate
until the 60s it is it is a it's a
matter of scholarly dispute as to what
was the cause that it I think it's
certain at this point there was no one
cause well first date may have had
something to do with it but I think it
may have just been changing norms in the
culture what because we're seeing the
same thing happen in in in the white
working-class as well now with the
decline of of two-parent homes to a
lesser extent than has happened in the
black community
yes so so I guess what yeah so I mean we
could talk about some of the the most
important behavioral patterns that are
different between black families and and
white families and Asian families I mean
there there are some statistics that I I
just I don't see any way in which this
could possibly be explained by systemic
racism for example one is that if you
ask thirteen year olds if they've had
their first sexual experience yet you
get nine percent of whites saying yes
you get twenty one percent of black
people saying yes right so it's more
than a two-fold difference there and
that has everything to do with family
dynamics with with their not being -
parents in the home it is a development
issue more than it is an issue of
treatment by white people right I have
another piece in Collette called black
American culture and the racial wealth
gap where I talk about spending
differences and you you you know Nielsen
the the marketing firm has done done
research on this found that the average
black woman is more likely to own a
luxury vehicle than the average white
woman despite the fact that the average
black family has one-tenth the wealth of
the average average white family
spending patterns on on jewelry and an
expensive clothes are very different in
the black community whatever you want to
say about these
ethically this is not I mean I'm not
ready when I make an ethical judgment
right I mean I'm not finger-wagging of
people saying do X don't do y I'm saying
there are there are entire books written
by respected left-wing scholars about
issues like wealth or income or that
just don't mention a single one of these
facts as if it's not relevant right so
what's what's the through line then or
the connection between all of this and
the welfare state because the more that
I've explored these ideas the more that
I am starting to buy that that almost is
the the real problem here that we've
given a certain amount and then it's
just human nature people don't want to
stop being on the dole that has nothing
to do with race you could give it to
anyone but in this case we happen to be
talking about black Americans but I can
give you just one simple example which
is my sister lives in in Manhattan not
that far from you actually and she's in
a building that's part subsidized so
there's a lot of black people in the
building that have been there for
generations now that are they're
subsidized my sister and her husband two
kids they're not rolling in dough
they're paying full market price but the
people that are in the subsidized
housing it's almost impossible for them
to leave I don't even blame them because
they're paying next to nothing and if
they wanted to work more they'd probably
and then get off the subsidy the
subsidies they probably have to leave
the building in the first place I think
I live somewhere worse so we end up with
this horrific catch-22 then again I
don't believe I don't put this on race
it just seems to be affecting people of
a certain race more yes I think I mean I
think it's clear that there was a point
in in in the late 60s and 70s where the
welfare state was clearly incentivizing
counterproductive behavior
disproportionately among black people I
mean the reason I yeah I I don't I think
we need a welfare state I think there's
there's really no free market there's no
capitalist economy in the world that
doesn't have one because they're just
and and you know people's jobs are being
taken by automation
and that's only going in one direction
and we clearly need a welfare state and
we need one that doesn't incentivize you
know counterproductive behavior and we
haven't always had that and when you say
welfare say you mean some sort of social
safety net that's what I yes okay
because I think people would you say
welfare state I think people have a
different sort of connotation traps yeah
I mean as social I mean something that
catches people who can't really can't
help themselves who can't trade their
skills for money in the market yeah yeah
I'm with you so so then how do we
untether
the issue of people that are now stuck
in that machine where every time you
talk about it you're called a racist no
I mean this is it is extremely precious
because I think it's clear that the
welfare state the way it was rolled out
in the 60s and 70s had bad effects for
black people right it's it's it's hard
to fully explain the decline in
two-parent homes without noticing that a
black mother in the early 70s stood to
lose money by getting married to a guy
right because of the perverse incentives
of the welfare state that said it's not
just because the welfare state was one
of the causes of the decline of the
black family doesn't imply that taking
it away would repair it
mmm-hmm so I think I think that is
something I charles murray for example
groped the big book in the 80s that made
him big losing ground which criticized
the welfare state very much along these
grounds but I think even he has
acknowledged that at this point removing
it once you set it all into motion it's
not obvious that removing it is a cure
which is which is tragic but true yeah
it's it's a real tragedy because then
it's like I mean this is where you would
definitely have a difference of opinion
with Candace where her argument is rip
the band-aid rip the band-aid let the
pieces fall where they may
I don't know what her policy is on then
helping like the poorest of the poor
whatever like are you literally gonna be
kicking people out of their houses right
I don't know what the answer to that is
yeah but I think there's there's a
growing feeling I think at least a
certain set of people that it's not
working you're acknowledging why it's
not working
these little band-aid fixes seemingly
only make it worse yeah it's I think
it's a very complex issue because there
there are some there are some elements
of the social safety net that I think
economists agree are working like the
Earned Income Tax Credit which actually
incentivizes you to work it helps the
worst off people in society without it
basically corrects the the massive
mistake of welfare in the Lyndon Johnson
era but ya know it's it's a complex
issue yeah sure so I hate to talk about
race this whole time it's like kind of
annoying I know it's what you mostly
write about what what else is kind of on
your mind like what are the other issues
that you care about I mean we can keep
going on that but I always feel like
it's like it's that's also a sort of
tragedy of all of this it's like your
whole worldview is to move past all this
yes and yet because of that you get
thrust into the conversation it's a
weird weird psychological condition I
suppose yes it is does that just drive
you crazy in general yeah I mean I don't
before we move on the race is not
something I find inherently interesting
yeah I think it is like when I have when
I have a free moment to to read a book
I'm not ordering the race book because
but but at the same time it is a topic
that's loomed so large in our politics
and so much of what is said makes so
little sense that I it it just gets to
me so I have to say something but it's
not something I enjoy I mean what I
really enjoy is philosophy and science
so so when I have free moments I tend to
read things and those in those genres
yeah well you're working for the right
lady Claire oh yeah collect yeah that's
what she cares about too so actually we
can shift a little bit so you attended
an event that there's an IDW group in
New York put together I was put together
in like two or three days it was me and
Eric Weinstein and Faizal Matar and and
Melissa Chen and we're just kind of
doing like IDW 101 stuff and you you
asked me an interesting question during
the Q&A so I'll let you present the
question and then I want to hear your
answer actually before I repeat my
answer yeah so my
question was essentially there are a lot
of people who really don't like the
intellectual dark web I think it's just
a bunch of cranks who are you know
playing footsie with the alt-right in
this objectionable way and totally
dismiss the whole thing but then there
there are there are many other people
who think well you know I I like I like
half of the people in the in the
intellectual dark web you know I don't
maybe like the other half but I think
it's they have it was kind of nuanced
take on it but they're really what where
one loses them is the fact that you know
you've had Stefan Mullen no
I don't know how to do Molyneux right so
this is this character that people view
as objectionable to whatever degree aI
don't know
I don't follow him so I don't know
whether they should or shouldn't view
him that way yeah but you know or sam
harris has had charles murray on the
podcast which you know many he just has
a terrible reputation on the left
largely undeserved yeah or Joe Rogan had
Alex Jones I think we can do endless
infinitum yeah and it seems like that is
is the last place where people who might
otherwise see this phenomenon as good
get off the ship
yeah or I've had I think I've had
conversations with people where that was
kind of the last trench to die in in
terms of criticizing the phenomenon so
my question was what do you like what do
you think about this do you think I mean
this is also a criticism that Barry
Weiss raised in her and her piece about
it so I mean I guess my answer to that
would be I'm I mean well do you know
this guy Darrell Davis he's a black guy
who did a documentary don't remember the
name of it where he met with the white
super he met with Ku Klux Klan members
yeah as a black person yeah and just
hung out with them talk to them about
various issues became friends with them
right so imagine the psychological
courage this takes to sit across from
someone who literally thinks you are an
inferior kind of human being and to put
that aside and
just expand your circle of empathy to
include them preemptively incredibly
inspirational so and he ends up getting
over 200 Ku Klux Klan members to
renounce their membership and he keeps
their robes in his closet as a kind of
trophy of having D radicalized them okay
and then he gets harshly criticized from
blacks black lives matter for having
having done this which is which I found
I find to be the most galling irony in
the world because we're talking about a
person who has done more to reduce
racism in the society than almost anyone
I could name in black lives matter right
he is he has gone like you know many
many progressive activists they attempt
to go to the spaces that are actually
the most progressive already and try to
make them even more progressive so they
show up on the University campuses
already the most progressive places on
planet Earth and then accused them of
being systemically racist right so we're
talking about a guy who actually went
into the trenches yeah
he was the belly of the beast exactly
and was successful in D radicalizing
people from white racism the the point
the point I'm making here is not not to
compare obviously charles Murray or
Stephan to to a Ku Klux Klan member my
point is we ought to be expanding the
range of people we're willing to talk to
and disagree with and I think that
insofar as you're able to challenge
people or just expose expose people's
ideas I think that in the long run as
uncomfortable as it is and
counterintuitive as it is tends to tends
to be better yeah so I'll just repeat it
quickly but that in essence that last
portion especially really was my answer
now first off some of us rogon me and
Sam particularly we interview people so
we can't say were for you know plurality
of ideas and we want to talk to people
we disagree with in all that and then
only talk to people we agree with so
that means we are going to talk to some
of these characters without getting into
any of the specifics of the people that
I've had on the show of course sometimes
somebody you may not ask the right
question here or there I'm not even I'm
not even saying that that's what I did
or didn't do
you have like otherwise we're not taking
any risks and the group of people that
we'll talk to will become infinitely
smaller and smaller and smaller and also
will be sort of will be hostages to
people that don't like us in the first
place and that's what I'm more concerned
about it's like I don't want people who
don't want any conversation to be
happening at all to have ownership over
who I'm going to talk to you yeah now on
any specific moment could any of us do
something a little bit differently sure
but in essence yeah you're asking about
the gatekeeping that that Berry was
talking about yeah I don't even know
that it's it's for me to say and as I
said before you know we don't even have
it sound like we're walking around with
laminated cards and we go to a secret
meeting so right but I think the best
sunlights the best disinfectant I just I
just fundamentally believe that and as
far as I know no one was hurt by any of
the interviews that I've done and I
think I've I've helped a lot of people
that were maybe into some of those ideas
you know that was one that people were
giving me a lot of that's the day it's
the Darrell Davis phenomenon yeah yeah
so yeah nobody's lost I mean that's what
I really believe and maybe that's a
little rose-colored glasses of me but I
believe that you know when when people
were giving me crap for new and Alex
Jones it's like forget what he thinks
about things for a moment clearly
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people are watching this I came on on a
live show I said whatever I believe I
didn't lie about anything I said the
same things I say here and then I got
emails from his people saying you know I
never heard a decent liberal talk before
now I watched your interview with Brett
Weinstein so I go wow that's pretty cool
man
so I just think perhaps we and I mean
you and I in this case we just have a
little bit more tolerance for I don't
think if someone hears something it's
going to immediately infect them and
then they're gonna take that infection
and infect other people but I think a
lot of people operate in that prison I
think so I mean one of the reasons I
asked this question at the event is I
was glad you did by them yeah yeah it's
because for example Charles Murray has
retweeted some of my pieces and you know
I've gotten into exchanges with some of
my critics where I've I've kind of
talked them down off of the ledge of me
being a sellout
you know convince them that I'm I'm
operating in good faith and the trench
they're dying and criticizing me is well
Charles Marie retweeted you and he is XY
and Z therefore I I think a that's just
that's like two layers of ad hominem
yeah
ad hominem is attacking you instead of
your belief but attacking someone else
instead of your yeah that's a bit much
yeah it's ad hominem twice over but we
seem to be in this in this place now
where people like lists you know the
SPLC is making lists of people that are
bad people you know there was this
alternative influencer graph that you
probably saw them tried to link together
I didn't even know probably ten or
fifteen of the people on there and I
don't you know and I looked at the list
after where there including me in this
like crazy whatever it was white
supremacist list saying not only did I
not know plenty of the people several of
them I have muted because they hate me
so it's like like you just come together
with anyone that has walked past you
oh you shook hands with that guy you
didn't know he was too bad you're you're
screwed man yeah that's it no I think I
think I was telling this to you before
we film but I think we live in a
McCarthy estera with regard to
especially racism but also other other
isms I mean I hope historians look back
on it as that but you know we're getting
we're getting people fired for you know
for saying the n-word in an anti-racist
context you know Papa John's for example
you know the CEO of that got fired for
saying the n-word
there was no push back on that guy said
it in the context of an anti-racist
raises like recalling his the racist of
his youth and the heinous things they
would say yeah
right and gets fired it gets his name
taken off the gym of his local hometown
just gets his reputation deep sixed and
right so like this is happening it
happened a month later to to this
executive at Netflix who's in a meeting
about offensive words in Netflix is
comedy context so how do you have a
meeting about offensive words without
saying offensive words right unless
you're just gonna be talking like
alphabet time so he says this fired so
these are note
nobody upon reflection thinks that these
people are racists it is completely it
is it is analogous to McCarthyism in
that sense and the word racism has been
denuded so fully of of its
of its moral valence and its moral
charge at this point that you know
people you know we're caring less and
less about actual racism to that's a
fear here like once you once you strip
this word of all it's all its moral
charge then you have a boy who cried
wolf scenario which ends up backfiring
spectacularly and I would argue that
that is happening we're seeing a surge
on the on the far right as well all
right so I think that that was also my
concern I mean before the election I did
plenty of videos about you got to stop
calling Trump Hitler yeah because if he
is not Hitler and for all the reasons
that people don't like him the guy's not
Hitler
and it's like you keep doing that you
won't even realize when the real bad
guys go and the people that would be
sympathetic to your views will no longer
listen to you because they'll view you
as the boy who cried wolf
yeah and Bill Maher Bill Maher called
himself out for doing this for calling
Bush and Romney racists or whatever it
was right he said that Romney hated
women yes yes and he called himself out
for being hyperbolic so that when when
trunk Trump came along who actually has
done clearly measured has said clearly
misogynist things is alleged to have
said some things that if he did say them
are clearly racist people don't care
anymore
because they've been so sullied you know
they've been called racist a thousand
times by the pundits at MSNBC and it's
it's been true maybe ten percent of the
times but not true like for the funniest
case of this to me was one when Trump
called Omarosa a dog right and watch you
turn on NBC MSNBC after this or read the
New York Times it is just obvious to
those people that this is a racist
threat he's called this black woman a
dog this is obviously racist and if
you're defending it you're a racist too
okay and then you just if you have an
internet connection
yeah you look at the other people Trump
has
directly called the dog you find Mac
Miller before he passed away you find
David Axelrod you find Adriana
Huffington
you find white person after white person
that he is directly called the dog not
said they did something like a dog
because he'd up he likes that
construction - right but he's called the
white person after wipers and a dog
there's no reason to believe that this
was a racist incident and yet every
pundit at MSNBC is saying that it is and
anyone who likes Trump and watches Fox
News they're getting these clips
exported from MSNBC seeing themselves
called as racist by a called racist by
implication or by association and then
seeing someone like Tucker Carlson who I
have I have reservations about but
seeing someone like Tucker Carlson make
perfect sense about it just destroy the
this view with with simple logic and
facts and imagine how how refreshing it
is to have someone like Tucker doing
that and obviously like you're gonna get
tired of being called a racist in in
cases when it's so obviously not true
and there's just a lack of due diligence
there's a lack of any concern for for
facts and for logic and that ends up
having a very bad effect on the other
end because now Trump I mean there some
things Trump has said for which racism I
think is the best explanation I don't
think he's a Klan member I think he's a
very mild kind of New York racist of his
era you know they're their degrees of
racism in other words but the point is
it's like the the reason that Trump
voters I think for the most part excuse
him on some of the things he said is is
not because or not for the most part
because of a random upsurge in racism
that happened in 2016 but wasn't present
the past eight years you there like
there are counties that went for Obama
twice that one for Trump it is it is I
think it's largely because people are
absolutely sick of being tarred as
racists untethered to the facts of the
specific cases yeah
now we've got just the match made in
hell we've got a group that calls
everyone racist the guy who you know is
happy to fight them on every bit of it
and use that as fuel to get his base
going yeah so what do you it's some time
well I said we were gonna shift that
race and we went right back to recycle
yeah all right we're gonna try to finish
up with science but what do you even
consider yourself politically these days
if I if I was trying to label you I mean
I have a sense you know you're somewhere
in that classical liberal situation but
does that even matter to you do you do
you think of yourself a certain way I
think if you can be gender fluid you
should be able to be politically fluid
at this point yeah I think I know a
white woman I I find your little things
used to be I appreciate that I
appreciate that um no but I think I mean
it is it is strange that like politics
is a social construct political
ideologies these are fully social
constructs and it seems like we're
getting more and more rigid with the
degree to which we take them seriously
obviously once you take ideas seriously
but I don't see anything to be gained
from anchoring myself to conservatism or
liberalism or libertarianism even though
I find wisdom in all of these three
political ideologies so yeah I mean I
think I think if I can if I can make
politically fluid a meme that would be
that would be great I will see what I
can do all right give me one other thing
besides race what do you do it for fun
tough things man I'm reading a reading a
lot about I'm taking metaphysics taking
philosophy of language in mind both of
which what are you doing pass on reading
metaphysic you got a political future in
front of you oh god no right people
often ask me that no I would never go
into politics actually people assume
that about me
which i think is really interesting
because I detest politics I hate it so
much
ya know I don't I don't know I don't
know why I give that vibe off but it's
yeah I cannot see myself as a politician
you're too sane that's the problem it's
been a pleasure man likewise all right
for more on Coleman follow
on the Twitter at cold X man
[Music]